Hello Freak bitches. Well, it becomes
a thing like with Floyd Mayweather,
you know,
like a big thing about Floyd Mayweather
is how much money he makes is not just
that he's a great boxer.
It's that he's going to make $300 million.
Apparently it's gonna be even more than
that. And you see the paper view numbers,
they're talking about 6.5
million paper view bys. Wow.
So it's more than 2 million more than
the Manny Pacquiao fight. That's insane.
Does that include the re
potential refunds? Did they
that's good question. Well,
to be fair, he did nickname of self
money Mayweather. Well, he did.
He was pretty boy Floyd. He
changed it, but yeah. Then
he built the persona around,
I spend money he doesn't have to do.
I mean it is cool and good for him,
but he did make a big thing about spitting
money that one time he showed up like
a hundred million dollar check
was so stupid. I'm like, wait,
why is that on like a regular ass check?
Yeah.
She was just like in a
regular chase bank check.
It wasn't even a big cardboard one.
Nate even net or print it
out or print it out on a,
or even a wire or something. I wouldn't
get that wire. Yeah, laminate that thing.
I think that's real. He's really
holding on to a $100 million check,
but it was just a regular ass check that
you would buy groceries on in eighties
yeah. Yeah. That 100 million. Yeah.
I guess he wrote it to himself. So it's
made with it promotions. General artists.
Yeah. Yeah. You got 100 million
in a bank of America, I guess so.
It seems like he just holds onto
it too. Hey, he doesn't catch it.
That's a weird out of his book bag at one
of the, uh, yeah, I saw it, but I mean,
why is he hanging on to that?
Why does it,
but you should probably catch
that in his other account anyways,
this Mayweather promotions account.
Who cares instead of bay where the
personal account, the checking.
So he's probably gonna make more than
$300 million from this last fight.
Sure. Yeah. Amazing.
I can't imagine that
they won't do that again.
That him and Connor won't do it again
with a wet finger if he kind of can figure
out how to not get tired.
If he could convince people like say
if he fights Paulie Malignaggi he's in.
That beats the shit out of
Paulie Malignaggi and then
says Freud do it one more
fucking time. And I think
Floyd, Nah man, come on.
We did that.
Oh I know.
He starts thinking about
that and money could bro,
if you can figure out a way to
get people excited about it,
Connor could get somehow,
somehow or another get more people
to pay attention because it was an
interesting fight for the first
three or four rounds. It's made it,
he made it look interesting,
but it really wasn't interesting.
I thought it was interesting, but then
when I thought back it wasn't interesting.
Well he caught point clean.
You know,
he caught him with an
uppercut in the first round.
Nobody hits Floyd clean like that. Lloyd
underestimated in my thoughts. So wasn't,
he wasn't doing that shoulder roll.
No, he was. Cause he wanted to,
he didn't believe in kindness pops.
So Floyd usually boxes and you think
that's what it is when you always see him
boxing that like he box
Canelo and he does that and,
and he goes off of that counter.
I don't think that's what it was.
I think he knew the Conner was going
to get tired if he was backing up.
You know that Connor has an
endurance problems and uh,
as long as he wasn't throwing a
lot of punches, which Floyd wasn't,
and he's constantly faking and moving,
he's got kind of backing up. He could be,
it's way easier to be defensive
if you're not being offensive.
So if you're not thinking
about hitting the guy,
if you're constantly like fainting and
you got your hands up and you're moving
forward, but really what you're
thinking about is what he's throwing,
you can get away with a lot and you're,
you can press forward a lot more because
you're going to see the punches coming.
Cause you're not really thinking too much
about throwing your own punches unless
he's like a clear wide opening.
So for the first couple of rounds,
he's mostly like putting pressure on them,
sizing.
And Mom when I watched it after the fight,
it became way more obvious like why
you're watching it. You're like,
what's going to happen? What's going
to happen once you already know what's,
what's happened? Then uh, then
I watched it and I said, oh,
I could see exactly what he's doing.
He's fainting,
putting a lot of pressure on Conor
and he's making kind of backup a lot,
which is exhausting.
And then also kinda is not very efficient.
He's not a boxer. So like there's a
lot of energy being wasted. Like he,
he's going to get tired more
easily and then he doesn't run.
So he doesn't have the same kind of
endurance of Floyd has. It's a lot,
a lot of factors in there.
Yeah. It was a Honda 11 punches,
but some of them were like, yeah,
all the ones that Connor landed.
You mean it was a few of them that were
like little [inaudible] yeah. Yeah.
There were also like
weird ones like patty,
patty peck punches to the side of the
head. They in the back of the head.
This is one meme that it sells is kind
of this and it just says fuck this box
and shit. Well, you know,
you get used to that in MMA.
You know you get used to hammer fists.
Well, I think that's what I saw.
I was talking about the ENA and a lot
of other people were just wondering if
muscle memory is going to just kick
in and he was going to do some weird
information and it did kick in a little
bit, but not to the extreme. Yeah,
there was some massive penalties for any,
so if he had any sort of a point
deduction or anything that they did,
is something illegal.
I think he had a massive penalty,
more than a million dollars for
each thing. He fucked up 10 mil,
10 mil each one.
That makes sense.
That tin mill makes you get your
shit together. As long as he's not,
doesn't get disqualified.
It might be worth it.
Like 10 million for one
fucking knee to the body.